on essaye d'être honnête
pardon de cette de cette phrase de la
présentation nationale mais pour faire
baisser chiffre d'affaires c'est pas
très compliqué vous dites au commissaire
de police à partir de octobre vous
n'enregistrez plus les les dossiers
comme ça vous comptez en dixième en 9e
de et puis après vous dites bah ça c'est
pour janvier prochain
délinquance statistiquement je crois que
il y en a qui l'ont fait il y en avait
pour essayer de résoudre des problèmes
parce qu'après les gens voient que c'est
un problème bon nous on essaye de dire à
un moment où la plainte est déposée on
l'enregistre comme étant la plainte du
jour premièrement donc on triche pas sur
les stocks deuxièmement la difficulté
que nous avons elle est importante c'est
que nous avons une multiplicité
désormais de contentieux et bien sûr les
violences conjugales ont complètement
changé la façon de fonctionner la police
et ta gendarmerie puisque nous avons dit
armées policiers aux gendarmes non
seulement vous ne prenez plus aucune
main courante mais vous déposez tout en
plainte ou en ouverture si c'est un
signalement pour que le procureur de la
République puisse faire évidemment une
poursuite et par ailleurs vous vous
concentrer sur les plaintes physiques
les plantes qui touchent les personnes
et on verra les plaintes des biens plus
tard je caricatures mais c'est grosso
modo j'avais qu'à comprendre que il vaut
mieux s'occuper des personnes que des
biens quand on doit faire deux urgences
du coup les stocks c'est surtout des
stocks de bien ça peut être aussi des
soldes de personnes mais des plantes
contre ces gens qu'on retrouve pas donc
le premier sujet c'est un peu on a été
un peu structurellement il y a des
stocks dans la police nationale par
manque de PJ par une grosse délinquance
qui existe deuxièmement ça a été aggravé
par le fait qu'on leur a dit en priorise
les violences personnes et notamment les
violences conjugales sur lesquelles à
chaque fois je répète quand même c'est
quasiment systématiquement la mise en
garde à vue de la personne qui est
accusée quasiment systématiquement la
saisie des arbres et les perquisitions
des enquêtes de voisinage et
psychologiques donc désormais pour 400
000 interventions par an c'est le
chiffre de l'année 2022 par exemple pour
les violences conjugales ça a créé voilà
beaucoup d'espace de police judiciaire
et c'est normal pour pour ces personnes
troisièmement on a mis beaucoup de monde
sur les sur la voie publique et plus
vous mettez des policiers dans la rue
alors ça c'est policiers gendarmes et
c'est aussi vrai pour les polices
municipales je prends l'exemple
Tourcoing je me rappelle façon on va
ensemble au commissaire Tourcoing le la
personne qui s'occupe de la du gage il
vous dira mais moi la police municipale
la même quasiment toute la journée des
gens qui font infraction routière et il
faut aussi les traiter donc il y a les
effectifs qu'on a mis en plus sur la
voie publique et quand je rajoute des
CRS et des gendarmes mobiles comme c'est
le cas de 11 escadron aujourd'hui qui
font de la sécurisation de lutte contre
les quartiers dans les quartiers des
visites contre la drogue etc vous faites
plus de dossiers et quand en plus les
maires augmentent le nombre de policiers
municipaux ce matin tôt j'étais à
Saint-Denis il y a désormais quasiment
une centaine de policiers municipales à
Saint-Denis ils apportent au
commissariat des enquêtes
supplémentaires donc les effectifs en
plus de tout le monde apporte des
enquête